you're watching white here's what we've
got for you in the next ten minutes
Thomas gets a lesson in blockbuster
treatment at one of the UK's top visual
effects companies I find out what
commuters think of the app that helps
pregnant women get a seat on public
transport and we're finding our way
through the darkness in our games review
welcome justice white you can't have
fell to notice it's movie awards season
right now but what you might not know is
that London is fast becoming a hub for
world-class of visual effects this week
Thomas has been finding out just how
much work is involved in creating a
blockbuster after the cameras have
stopped rolling
cheer for blunt
Garfield a British Invasion of Hollywood
but it's not just with the box office
stars where the UK is flexing its cinema
muscles London's visual effects sector
is booming small independence as well as
big-name companies are leading the way
jellyfish pictures employs just 170
people and makes effect for everything
from children's TV right up to
oscar-nominated blockbusters like Star
Wars rogue one hours of work can go into
making a single frame creatures so
mainly big creatures small creatures
anything down to you know tiny little
bees we've done before
and you have to do the animations on all
these things you have to start from
scratch so to start from a concept
design of what the bee actually looks
like and to actually serve modeling and
actually making us a CGI element that
feels a bit tactile if you were going to
touch it and it's got wings it's got
feet it's got eyes and through that we
now have another element that looks like
it could have been shot by the director
himself virtual effects are worth an
estimated 400 million pounds to the UK
film economy but brexit has cast a
shadow on the sector's future it will
mean we're going to have to look a lot
harder for UK talent there is something
like 600 graduates coming out of college
I've been told every year
from VFX courses and animation courses
in the UK but unfortunately not all of
those people are ready to come in to
work more and more blockbuster
productions are coming to London for
world-class and visual effects like
these in just six years the workforce
here has grown by 600 percent the job
now is keeping up with that demand and
these are people that you've done on a
green screen Allen came to the UK to
study and was happy to find himself at
the centre of Europe's VFX Capitol if
you walk around central you're gonna
stop by the effects companies all the
time and this is just great if I live
here I have the opportunity to apply for
all these companies in central London
and I've been to a lot of talks for the
really big visual effects companies and
all of they keep telling me they have to
specialize the industry is young and
Britain is succeeding now it's a case of
keeping that edge Thomas Newton Sky News
stay with us still to come would you
download an app to help pregnant women
get a seat on the bus or train are we
speaking to the man behind that app
after a roundup of this week's tech news
the Queen's been learning about the
threat of hackers this week Her Majesty
officially opened the new national
cybersecurity Center which launched last
year experts say Britain faces an
increasing threat from cyberattacks
Dubai wants to have a passenger carrying
drone up and running this July the head
of the country's roads and
transportation agency made the
announcement about the Chinese made even
184 on Monday it can reportedly carry
people weighing up to 100 kilos along
with a small suitcase and has a battery
life of half an hour his reported naki
is bringing back one of its most
successful handsets from nearly 20 years
ago the 3310 is rumoured to be up for
re-release this month at the Mobile
World Congress event in Barcelona
Santander has become the first UK bank
to let customers make payments by
talking to an app the bank says the
voice activation technology currently
running as a pilot also means users can
check their balances and recruit lost
cards
who fancies a bit of submarine combat
stick around it's coming up in our
gained review but before that now last
month a new app launched to help
pregnant women get a seat on public
transport now the makers say it's
expanding to 155 countries is called
baby on board and was created by a
British entrepreneur who apparently felt
guilty after he didn't offer his seat to
a pregnant lady when he was too busy
looking at his phone so I went to meet
him I began by asking for a recap on how
the app works it's very simple
pregnant person downloads request see
how then they press the button and that
sends a notification to everyone the
tube they're pregnant and would like to
see then if you've got a companion app
officee then you'll get a notification
comes up that says heads-up there's a
pregnant person near you would you like
to give up your seat so the other
commuters have to have downloaded the
companion app for it to work basically
that's correct so in your first month
then how successful does it be so a
month ago we launched a london-based
trial and we've had two thousand
downloads in three weeks
which we think is pretty good we set our
sales 50% at their target and we smashed
it how do you know that 2,000 is a good
amount in a city like London so we've
talked to statisticians and we've talked
to other app developers in terms of the
total universe of London
it's a pretty decent amount
good idea bad idea I think it's a
wonderful idea but I can't imagine
enough people using it you need the
people who are not pregnant but the the
non pregnant people who are considerate
of pregnant people to download it I
think if you get that that would be
great
I've been pregnant on tubes and I think
I stood up I don't really use the train
and I assume it wouldn't work on a tube
so I okay be honest with you I think
common courtesy I would probably just
stand when I saw a woman that was
pregnant anyway I don't think a nap
would help me in that regard
unless you're pedaling or somebody in
your family is pregnant there'll be no
real reason for you to have an app like
that the pregnant women also have to pay
for the app is that right yeah but
that's a result of not having kids
downloading it and trolling people you
know so we've just about 100% of all the
profits go to charity what do you think
is the biggest problem faced by
entrepreneurs like you in Britain at the
moment big problem we face is talent and
it's finding the right people often they
get sucked up into huge big companies
like Facebook and Google we're looking
to employ people who say I experts
machine learning and those people want
to go and work for the big tech
companies and so to actually get them to
come work for startup you've got to have
a really feeling proposition and it
could have faith that you can kind of
deliver and create some really amazing
products what do you do about that
you're going global now really it's
about trying to convince people selling
the vision and getting them on board and
hoping that actually they don't want to
go work for a big Facebook or they want
to come and do something that actually
matters let us know what you think of
the app tweet us at Sky News swipe
videogames time now and this week holly
has been reviewing a few recent titles
for us diluvian is a steampunk jules
verne inspired submarine adventure which
has combat and a lot of exploration the
idea is that hundreds of years ago there
was a great flood and now humanity finds
itself trapped under ice under water so
every settlement you come across is just
a collection of kind of scrappy metal
holls clinging to the ice and a
desperate attempt to keep alive when you
go out in your submarine and you go out
to gather your crew and to increase the
how effective your submarine is there's
a lot you have to consider so you need
to consider oxygen to keep your crew
alive you need to have food to keep them
alive now this all sounds really good
and it's a great idea however the
frustrating user interface and a very
poor checkpointing system does let it
down candle man is a 3d puzzle
platformer in which he plays a little
candle that wants to seek a greater
light in the darkness now the whole
mechanic around this is based on as the
candle you can light yourself up to 10
seconds at every level so lighting the
way in the very dark levels and now but
by doing this you also burn down your
own candle so there's a battle between
wanting to conserve your own wax and
keep the character alive but then also
lighting the way and it makes with some
really interesting mechanics and the use
of light and dark leads to some really
lovely art design now it begins very
interesting and there's some great ideas
and there however the later levels do
let it down a little bit and the ending
isn't that great so that's a little bit
disappointing however if you're looking
for an interesting tipping a bit
different to play on the Xbox one that I
think candle man is definitely one to
look out for Nintendo have bought their
adorable platformer from the Wii U to
the 3ds and it is just as lovely this
game just has so much charm that you
just have to look at it and the detail
that everything is made out of wool or
yarn or cloth
the details are absolutely lovely it's
impossible not to be charmed by this
game now there's a bit more to it than
just a straightforward port they have
added so many features so there are some
new exclusive levels but the main thing
is poochy
Yoshi's little dog friend he was
utilized within some of the levels in
some really interesting ways there's
also the new ability to design your own
yarn Yoshi which is lovely works really
well so if you had the game before and
the Wii you then
maybe there might not be enough to
justify it to get it again on the 3ds
however he is still retained all its
charm all it's lovely aesthetic Ness
just how gorgeous it is has worked
really well in the 3ds and so I would
highly recommend it as it for this week
but if you've just caught the end of
wight don't worry you can catch up with
all of our episodes on demand and all
the usual places I'll be back next week
guide you can join us then the way
[Music]